mr. Lumm how are you and what are your
first impressions of Russia I'm doing
great because I'm back at a World Cup
and that's always something special I
get to watch lots of games and that's
really nice what do you like about
Russia at the moment I'd say that the
people here are really excited about the
World Cup they're happy that they can
host such a massive event will we see
you at a public viewing in Moscow
probably watching the games at the
stadium instead but I'm not here for
long so I look forward to enjoying the
games from home this time around and
watching on TV the last time I watched a
world cup on TV was in 2002 so it's
really nice to be able to experience it
from home again what's it like as a
retired footballer what do you feel when
you see other people playing the game
stepping away from the game has meant I
see things differently it's really nice
that I can appreciate things differently
than I could during my playing days when
you're playing you have to be so focused
on the games ahead now I can look at the
stadiums and experience everything that
happens around the matches and that's
fantastic because you really get to see
things from a different perspective if
you compare the preparations for the
last World Cup which of course ended
very successfully with this tournament
do you think there are similarities we
know that yogi love will prepare this
team meticulously he has experience he
knows how to set a team up he knows how
to get ready for a tournament and the
players are experienced many of these
players have been to big tournaments
before so I have a really good feeling
how do you see Germany performing well
as I said there are players in this
squad who have plenty of experience some
have already been to big tournaments
they all play for clubs in the best
leagues that also play in international
competitions like the Champions League
but there are also young talents in the
squad who are a breath of fresh air and
are also gaining some experience I mean
couldn't
on deflation Etrigan zone team bringing
up good what about the other teams who
are your favorites my favorites are
Brazil Argentina the Spanish and French
and of course the Germans the Deutsch
that's not just Philipp Lahm thank you
my pleasure